Sở xe dự nửa sất ý bán nhân dân thành phố Hàn Nội trước thận cho công ty hết Mở xe
sự chữ hình cấp các hạn mục hôm tại một số nhà gà thuộc dưới Mê Chô
Các Linh, Hà Nông.
Theo đó, các hạn mục đục sở xe dự hạn Nội kinh nghị
sự chữ hình cấp ông, Mài Chè trên nóc nhà gà ý nghĩa,
các Mài Chè thằng cuốn và kính bị vớ, nước tại một số nhà gà trên
Tuyên Mê Chô số 2, các Linh, Hà Nông.
Bực sự chữ được nửa sất sau cho công ty chế giám hiểu hạn mùa thành viên đường
sất hạn Nội, Hát Mở xe với yêu cầu phải bảo đam tuy đối ăn tòn vận hạn.
Bảo đam chứ lượng dịch vụ vận tại hạn khách công cộng ít người anh gửi hạn khách
thực hiện xong trước ngày 1 xong thằng xong năm 2020.
Sở xe dự hạn Nội cũng đề gì Hát Mở xe tổ chức bảo dưới thử
xuyên tòan bộ các đàn tạo, bảo chí kết cố hạn tần đường sất đô thị theo cuy chình
quy định để bảo đam ăn tòn vận hạn không để xe ra sự cố anh gửi hạn khách.
Chưa đó tại gà in giã, tấm lợp mai chê thành quấn nhả gà được thích kế làm bằng vật liệu dự thông minh giống bộ lợp
dây hai sên tìm mẹ, Mở xanh cũng theo dự ăn được dự bị hư hồng, tốt mai chưa được dự chứ.
Bình cạnh đó, lăng caan kinh cụ lực tại gà văn quán, ra thượng đình, gà lắng, cũng bị hớ, nhưng đồ cần được thái thiếc,
nước trẻ trong toa tạo hát đời không không một cần sớm được khách phục.
Nguyên nhân hư hồng được sắc định là gió anh rộng của bảo số 3 từ quối thằng chiến năm 2020.
Hình, tình mẹ châu nay vẫn đặc khai thác sịch vụ, tình xin quy một năm 2020 đã có bá phẩy hai bà trịu lực khách sử dụng.